she has gone skydiving in New Zealand
and Vancouver
what you think about is probably about
the same latitude right probably very
similar geological features I'm hoping
same air you're flying for the same air
right all right everyone please welcome
her off
hi everyone
um
my name is Moravia blifker I'm the CEO
and co-founder of data Society I think
my talk is a little bit the opposite of
Tommy I have like zero math not
technical
um so we're finishing out the day with
um
talking about about data which is really
what this conference is about
so in order for you to know where I'm
coming from let me just give you a bit
of a background data Society is a
company I helped start back in 2014. in
a nutshell we help professionals use
data better we deliver custom data
science training programs to large
organizations Fortune 500 companies and
other large organizations and we also
use them Consulting projects as well to
kind of come out of that mostly to do
with building software predictive
algorithms
but the reason we really got started is
because back in 2014 I did not know data
science I am actually an educator at
heart I started my career in New York
City Public Schools teaching Elementary
special education
uh still the hardest job I've ever had
and so I was really good at education
and I used data to inform the decisions
that I was making but as I was trying to
learn more I couldn't really find
anything that spoke to me as a
professional
so um Serendipity happened I met with a
few friends and we all saw the same
problem in different fields and decided
hey if we can't find it let's build it
and so we ended up building those types
of solutions and we're still here eight
years later so we must be doing
something right
um for today
as a teacher I always like to put my
objectives up for anybody who knows
um and I need to remember what they are
so I'm going to look up uh we're going
to talk a little bit about
professionals and some of the challenges
that they're still facing today some of
the trends that have changed from 2018
to now and then some of the things that
you can do to uh help increase being
data driven within your organization so
I know I'm not allowed to take questions
from you but that doesn't stop me from
asking you questions so just out of
curiosity how many of you work with data
today
that's like almost everyone
um how many of you have colleagues or a
manager that don't really know what you
do
okay also a lot of people right so this
is something that we actually found to
be a really big challenge because the
lame joke that I like to say is if a
data scientist finds an Insight but
nobody around her understands it doesn't
matter right and so what we see all the
time is you have these really amazing
data professionals who want to have an
impact but they can't convey it
appropriately because people don't know
what they're talking about they don't
know what they're saying they don't have
the right resources and so what we
really found is that it's actually a
communication gap there's no common data
vocabulary
and
um that's really one of the big
challenges that we solve
and
um you know why is it so important it's
because without having data literacy
um you know your organization your
company it's they're gonna fall behind
right there's a lot of data out there
they need to be able to use that
effectively
um and I like to show these types of
Statistics to the executive audiences
that I present to the people who don't
use data on a regular basis because I
want them to understand exactly how
important it is
um most I would say most Industries
today are still not using data the way
that they need to be using it and it's
not because of anybody in this room you
all are doing a great job it's because
everybody else is still having
difficulty understanding what that
really means
okay and these are again these are some
numbers I think back from 2020 I would
say they're still true today if not more
um a lot of people still feel really
overwhelmed with data you know we talk
to a lot of folks who are like buried in
Excel spreadsheets
um or doing SQL queries all the time
because their colleagues don't know how
to do them I see some heads that are
nodding right they're asked to build
these Tableau dashboards to look at one
metric that like nobody ever needs to
look at again so we're seeing a lot of
wasted time a lot of wasted energy
because people are not able to
communicate
and you know we see what the impact can
have here
um Advanced organizations are more than
20 percent uh what did I write up here
uh more profitable right
um and so
think about these numbers
um and I will tell you how you can
leverage this uh later in the talk
so with that
um let's turn back time a little bit
to 2018 2018 black panther came out
people were eating Tide Pods uh I think
do you guys remember this I didn't
understand what this was but it was a
thing it was a thing now people are
doing other things like drinking bleach
I don't know it's the whole thing
um and then like Beyonce absolutely
crushed it at Coachella
um K-pop also became a lot bigger Harry
married Megan you guys remember that
when they were still Royal yeah that was
like a big deal
um and so a lot has changed
and um you know what we were seeing in
terms of data Trends right so first off
there was a lot of data pipelines that
were being built a lot of focus on that
um there's also a lot of advances in NLP
like obviously Tommy's continuing that
Trend in 2022 and uh what we're also
seeing is that there was increased
Demand on model interpretation
uh and back in 2018 we were seeing these
communication issues so we decided to do
a survey
um so we released a survey was like I
just put basically a blog post on medium
I created a survey that was I know maybe
15 questions or something like that that
was about the plight of the frustrated
data scientists right because we kept
hearing this story again and again
and here were the results that we saw
so back in 2018
um you know we saw that leadership and
other non-data people didn't really
understand uh what data was
um 30 of of data professionals times
were spent on explaining what they do to
others does this resonate with anyone
here again seeing some heads not and
Magic
um did you guys know magic existed
it does in data apparently because
everyone thinks that it is Magic to do
data science right managers people who
didn't have an understanding of that and
so that was a really big pain point and
so from that we said okay well how can
we Empower data professionals to
overcome this challenge
so we created a toolkit back then
and what it was is it essentially was a
presentation that combined all of these
different myths and tried to dispel them
in a presentation 20 to 30 minute talk
that anybody could download and put on
how to script head slides and had
everything else we got a really positive
feedback
and then you know we went back to
regular life people would keep
downloading it sometimes I'd get you
know emails saying hey this was really
helpful
and uh fast forward to 2022 again a lot
of things have changed right we got
covid we started to see data needs to be
everywhere big focus on data literacy
how many of you all have heard data
literacy of daily literacy before how
many of you all like have organizations
that are like we're going to be data
literate within the next five years
we're gonna do it
we have a few people who are like that
okay maybe not maybe you want them to be
I don't know
and we decided to rerun the survey
because we said well it's been a couple
of years what's what's changed
um the answer is sadly shockingly little
I wish I wish uh the results were
different
um keep in mind that the stamp the sizes
are quite different so I actually put
the survey link on one of the first
Pages please take it
um so that we can get your feedback and
your input and we can incorporate that
in here
there just are not that many big
differences right so when we ask the
question what do you want your manager
your leadership to know in 2018 it was
what data science can and cannot do and
now in 2022 it's really focused more on
how data science can impact the company
but they just switched there's not
actually a huge difference so it sounds
like four people kind of understand the
data is important but don't really
understand what to do with it right
um you know one of the things that again
is very similar when we ask this
question do you think your organization
is using data effectively
two-thirds of respondents said no
um just a show of hands how many of you
resonate with the two-thirds of
respondents that we got here
a lot okay take the survey so we can get
those those responses
um so we're still seeing this even
though I'm sure you've seen over the
past four years data everybody's talking
about data everybody says that they're
using data everybody's talking saying
that they're using AI right
um but are they really that's the
question that we were trying to answer
so some other trends that we were seeing
what are some of the biggest changes
we're seeing a lot more people are
hiring for data related roles there's
more training opportunities involved
pretty sure that's why we're still
around
um and then some of the biggest
challenges production
so we got a lot of comments about
putting work into scalable production
which we did not see in 2018 so that was
actually one of the bigger changes that
we saw
um people really want to get production
code up and running right we're seeing a
lot of platforms that are really coming
to the Forefront to empower that getting
access to the data that I need
um so you know this is for government
conference we do work with a lot of
government agencies one of the things we
see most often when we run some of our
programs is that our students can't
access the data sets that they need to
do the analysis that they want to do
sometimes it's for a good reason if
we're dealing with
um data that has you know hip our
personal information obviously there
need to be protocols in place but
equally
people are being prevented from doing
good work because they don't have access
to their data
and so again these are some of the
challenges that we see every day that
we're working with
um to overcome
you know something else that I thought
was was interesting misconceptions how
easy it is to gather data have you guys
have you heard this before have you
folks heard this like you're talking to
a manager about a project and it takes
you three to four weeks to even find the
data set and make sure that the data is
okay and then your manager is like oh
that should have taken like a couple
hours right
no no we all know how hard it is in this
room to collect data machine learning
Phil does magic apparently and
um this is an interesting comment that I
saw a few of data science can do
anything because Google does anything
Google can do anything and therefore we
as an organization can do anything that
Google does
again do they have the infrastructure in
place right
so we're seeing a lot of these
challenges that still exist
and we're doing a revamp for our toolkit
but what I want to do today in the last
eight and a half minutes that I have
with you is talk a little bit about what
you can do in order to go back to your
office to your team to your organization
and start to break down some of those
barriers that we see
so what does it really mean to be data
driven so we created these two axes this
might be familiar to you maybe you've
seen this before about what it means in
practice to be data driven so we have
data literacy and we also have data
infrastructure and as we can see you
know all the way up there in the top
right you're data driven if you have
solid data infrastructure people on your
team understand what data is they
understand how to ask the right
questions awesome you're there feel free
to close your eyes and just try not to
snore for the rest of this talk okay
otherwise you might have some work to do
and we actually have a
a questionnaire I think it's 10 or 20
questions that can actually help you
identify where you are now what's really
interesting and this is what we do uh
with a lot of folks is that
um different teams and different levels
have different responses so some people
think of course we're data driven I have
access to all the data that I need right
I have access to the infrastructure I
can access pause it or Python and others
say no I have no access to the data I
have no idea what my other team members
are doing and so a lot of times these
answers are different can be very
segmented
so let's look at the first axis which is
data infrastructure again as you're
talking about this with your colleagues
or as you're thinking about this for
yourself kind of ask yourself these
questions
um you have data collection you have uh
data storage and you also have data
security right so these are the three
pillars of data infrastructure
and this can mean different things to
different organizations right if you're
a healthcare organization obviously data
security needs something completely
different than uh if you're not right
and you also have to think about data
storage how is it backed up a lot of
things are in the cloud now I don't
think I know many folks that still do
anything on-prem
um but how is that backed up right how
is that backed up how is that accessible
so these are a few things that are
concrete pillars that you can go to your
leadership with or if you are leadership
you can go to your colleagues with to
talk about like where are we on these
things what do we have
on the other axis we have data
literature
um of data literacy excuse me so again
we have these three pillars here first
one is data leadership one of the
biggest uh factors that we found to be
either success or or not success when it
comes to implementing a larger
data-driven policy is is your leadership
uh bought in
can they allocate the resources can they
allocate the time do they understand
what it means to be data driven make
sure your leadership is on board data
governance is another big thing
how many of your organizations have data
governance have talked about data
governance or implementing data
governance
you oh I would I would get on that I
think that's that's a really important
component because data governance
essentially outlines the guidelines for
how to use data responsibly for example
there's a ton of dark data that exists
because people have a bunch of those
Excel spreadsheets downloaded to their
computer and not anywhere else right so
what happens when they leave and their
laptop gets wiped all of that data goes
down the drain
these simple guidelines of where to
store your data how to label your
columns how to handle data appropriately
minor guidelines that make a really
really big difference and last but not
least data knowledge does your staff
understand
um how to ask the right questions of
data one of the biggest things that we
see
if you're a data professional is they
get a lot of queries from their
colleagues about SQL queries
um about questions that are business
related but they're not really expanding
on what they really need and so there
are again these miscommunications
if your colleagues around you understand
how to use data how to ask questions
they feel empowered they can actually do
some of that work themselves and then
that leaves you to really dig into more
in-depth uh you know algorithms and
modeling and things like that
okay
I have four minutes left I think we're
good actually
how can you encourage data-driven
thinking so we've been doing this for
over eight years
um we've seen a lot of ways for this to
be implemented successfully
and it starts with you all who are in
the room
so the first thing that we like to say
is to be the role model yourselves
sometimes that sounds really daunting
but you can take one step at a time so
what does that really look like in
practice right
um if you are running a project or you
have colleagues that are doing an
analysis ask for those metrics
and show them what you mean if you if
you have a prototype there you can also
ask questions about the data dig into it
do people account for those biases where
is the data coming from are those models
valid have they been tested with real
world data
use tools and exercises to get people
out of the box
um demonstrate your decision making
during meetings so especially if you're
again in that leadership like literally
point to the chart that you are using to
inform your decision right be very
deliberate about that and start to show
people what that means to be data driven
and engage in creative thinking to drive
Innovation so one of the events that we
love to see are hackathons or lunch and
learns and I think I'm eating into my
next slide maybe a little bit
um so find ways to showcase the good
work that people are doing at the same
time
um provide people a safe space one of
the things that we see most often is
people are afraid to fail
they're like I'm gonna do this model and
if it doesn't turn out exactly right I'm
not going to be allowed to do anything
else
I think everyone in this room
understands the first time you run a
model
it's not going to be perfect right we
have to iterate sometimes we need to go
back and get more data or we need to
redefine the question itself be a safe
space for other people
let people explore their ideas help them
talk it through and provide them a place
to fail because that's how they learn
from it right and that's the best way to
to do any of these projects in in my
opinion is to be able to really learn
from our mistakes and if you provide
that safe space people are more likely
to take that risk themselves
so that's really important to do as well
um and last but not least is give
recognition people love to be recognized
and one of the biggest drivers that
we've seen to help Inspire others is
showing successful projects within an
organization so let's say you're on a
team that did great work maybe they
implemented a model they were able to
automate some processes put on a lunch
and learn you know put it in a
newsletter do a hackathon around the
next stage of it shout it from the
rooftops because other teams will see
that and they'll say oh you did this
within the restrictions that we have on
our networks you did this within
um our organization's Mission and I
actually think I have a similar problem
that we can solve right and and it's
really fun for the people who are doing
the hard work frankly you know it's
important to give recognition when when
that good work is done and also when
there are improvements that need to be
made
so
this was a very quick talk I have one
minute left so I think I I did really
well on timing
um but hopefully you're able to take
away some of these action items maybe
pick one that you think is that low
hanging fruit that you can go back to
your team with next week and just say
hey let's start using charts uh let's
start using the dashboards that we've
created to actually drive some of those
decisions that we're discussing
with that I'm going to finish out my
talk just to say if you want to learn
more about us you can go to data Society
you can also just email me I didn't
include my last name because nobody
would ever email me correctly so it's
just murav datasociety.com sure thank
you all so much